مساء الخير لكل اصدقائه الذين يسالون عن
ما يجري فيهم كون لا يمكن ان نفهم ما يحدث
الان دون ان نعود الى التعريف ونعرف حكايه
من البدايه وهي حكايه مثيره جدا ربما تكون
افضل البدايه هي السنوات القليله التي
سبقت حرب الافيون هي حرب الافيون عشان
نفهم حرب الافيون لازم نعرف انه من حوالي
مائتين وخمسين سنه كان هناك الصراع
اقتصادي ما بين الصين والدول الصناعيه
الغربيه الصاعده وعلى راسها بريطانيا جوهر
الصراع النصين الامبراطوريه العظيمه وقتها
كانت اكبر اقتصاد في العالم
وكانت تراقبها في ان تغلق حدودها على
نفسها ولم تكن تشعر ان العالم الخارجي
لديه ما يغريها باستيراده الامر اللي ادى
الى وجود فجوه كبيره جدا في المدار
التجاري يعني هي بتصدر للعالم الخارجيه
ولا تفسيرات اي شيء من بريطانيا كانت ترغب
في تغيير هذا الوضع فتح اسواق الصين
ويتصدر لها اكبر كم ممكن من البضائع
والخدمات سواء بشكل مشروع او بشكل غير
مشروع وبالتالي بدات في زياده وتيره ادخال
بضائع ها ومن بين هذه البضائع كان الافيون
اه والاخير كانت بسرعه في الهند المستعمره
البريطانيه القريبه من الصين وبدات تدخل
الاسواق الصينيه هذه البضاعه بدات ترويج ل
لانها اتمام طبعا بين الصينيين على مدار
خمسين وستين وسبعين سنه وزاره المساله
قبيل اندلاع حرب الافين الاولى اللي بدات
سنه تسعه وثلاثين الف تامير اثنين واربعين
انه كانت كتب التاريخ بتقول
الكبار البريطانيون شركه الهند الشرقيه
تابع طبعا البريطانيه بتدخل حوالي اربعه
الاف سنه الاربعه الاف شفنا دول كل شفنا
فيهم
حوالي سبعه وسبعين كيلو من الافيون اضرب
سبعه وسبعين كيلو في اربعه ثلاثه رقم ضخمه
جدا النتيجه ان وهذا اغضب الامبراطور صيني
لامرين الامر الاول انه بيتعارض مع ا
سياسته ال غير راغبه على الانفتاح في
العالم الخارجي الامر الثاني وهو الان
الاثار الاجتماعيه السيئه جدا الا اذا
كانت اللي ادت الى ادمان عدد كبير من
المواطنين الصينيين وبالتالي مشاكل
اجتماعيه وقله انتاج كلها مشاكل سيئه لما
الصين قرارات منع دخول هذه البضائع اللي
هي الافيون يعني والقت القبض على مجموعه
من البحاره البريطانيين واشتبكت معهم
اعتبرت بريطانيا هذه الحادثه سببا
للتدخل العسكري الصين وقد كان وده اطلق
عليها حرب الافيون الاولى ولا اطلق عليها
حرب الاثنين الاولى مجموعه من الشرفاء
الانجليز الا اعتبروها حرب غير اخلاقيه
لان الهدف منها تحقيق الربح لبريطانيا
العظمى باي وسيله حتى وان كانت وسيله غير
اخلاقيه طيب كانت نتيجه هزيمه الصين
المفاجاه والسريعه امام ال بريطانيا هو
مجموعه من الشروط المظله التي فرضت على
الصين جوهر هذه الشروط او خلاصاتها فتح
المدن او جزء من المدن الصينيه امام
البضائع البريطانيه وانتزاع جزء من من
الحاليه هم اخذوهم على مراحل طيب بعد كده
حرب الافيون مره اخرى فيما عرف
حرب الافيون الثانيه اللي انضمت فيها الى
جانب بريطانيا فرنسا
وكانت لاسباب المشابهه ان بريطانيا وفرنسا
ترغب في فتح المزيد من المدن الصينيه
والموانئ الصينيه امام التجاره مع العالم
الخارجي وكانت النتيجه انه صمت الصين مره
اخرى في الحرب اللي بدات سنه
1960 وخسرت فيها ايضا لصالح بريطانيا جزء
اخر منهم
اسمه كاولون ثم
بعد الاستيلاء على
قررت بريطانيا ان هي تستاثر لمده تسعه
وتسعين سنه كسره اخر
مجاور الها سميه بيرتس او الاراضي الكبيره
والنيوترينو يتولون مع هونغ كونغ الثلاث
اجزاء دون بيمثله او ب اه يعني تمثل
الحديث اللي احنا نعرفها الان هذا ما حدث
في التاريخ يعني انه خلصتوا ان الصين خسرت
الحاليه نتيجه صوره
خسارتها او هزيمتها المجله في حرب الافيون
الاولى والثانيه
بعد انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه وبدات
الصين قوه صاعده بدات تسعى الى استعاده كل
المناطق الخارجه عن سيطرتها اه عن السيطره
الصينيه وهم كانوا ثلاث اماكن على ثلاث
مناطق على وجه التحديد منطقه معك او اللي
كانت منطقه صينيه وصل محتله البرتغاليون
في القرن ال 16
وال هونغ كونغ وطبعا منطقه وانه وكثيره
طيوان احنا النهار ده على هونغ كونغ
فبدات مفاوضات مع بريطانيا انتهت في سنه
الف وتسعمائه واربعه وثمانين ووفقا لهذا
الاتفاق الذي اجري في هذا العام سوف تسترد
الصين
بكامله في 1 يوليو سنه سبعه وتسعين وهو ما
كان لواحد يوليو سنه سبعه وتسعين بالتاريخ
اللي كان ينتهي في عقد ايجار بريطانيا
لمنطقه الاراضي الجديده وفي هذه المناسبه
سوف تسترد الصين ايضا الاراضي التي تم
احتلالها يعني هم يقولون يعني باختصار
واحد يقول وسبعه وتسعين تسترد الصين كامل
هونغ كونغ باجزائها الثلاثه
لكن تضمن هذا الاتفاق شرطا مؤقتا ان تكون
ان تحظى هونغ كونغ اللي كانت مستعمره
بريطانيه بفتره انت فتره انتقاليه لمده
خمسين سنه تنتهي سنه الفين وسبعه واربعين
خلال هذه الخمسين سنه
تستطيع فيها كان
تنعم بنوع من الحكم الذاتي بحيث انه يكون
لها تحتفظ ب نظمها اللي كانت تعيش تحت في
ظل وفقا لل تحت الاحتلال البريطاني هو فقط
الصين وفقا لمبدا دوله واحده ونظامان يعني
دوله واحده هم جزء من الصين ايوه لكن تفضل
شغاله بنفس النظام اللي كان تعيش فيه تحت
النظام البريطاني والحقيقه ان الصين قابلت
ذلك لانها لاكثر من اعتبار الاعتبار
الاولاني انها كانت مستفيده من تجربه
الاقتصاديه الناجحه جدا باعتبرها كانت
معبر
العلاقه ما بين الصين والغرب وهي كانت
اللي هي اهم كونغ يعني كانت احد اهم اسباب
النهضه الاقتصاديه اللي حصلت في الصين
بدايه من السبعينات والى الان وبالتالي لم
تكن تمانع في هذا الامر مؤقتا الامر
التالي ان الصين ترغب في ان
تنجح علاقتها معهم وفقا لمبدا دوله واحده
ونظامان على
الجزء الباقي لان استردت استردت ما كانوا
من البرتغاليين سنه الف وتسعمائه تسعه
وتسعين سبعه فيها مشكله مع ما كان وبردو
خليتها منطقه حكم ذاتي
منطقه مكاو دي اللي بيسموها اسيا وبردو
منطقه غربيه في قلب الصين لك او في اطراف
الصين يعني لكن المتبقي هو منطقه طيب ان
اللي انفصلت عن الصين سنه تسعه واربعين
وهي بتحاول تقنع طيوان بالعوده اليها
بالتي هي احسن
ابني هي كلها زي ما تجربتي معهم
تحت ظل دوله واحده ونظامان انت كمانها
تبقى دوله جزء من الصين ولكن لك نظام ولكن
الديمقراطيه اللى انت عاوزها وحريه
التجاره وكل الامور
اللي انت ت ارهابيه علشان تبدد مخاوف
اهالي طيران صح انهم لم ينجحوا حتى الان
لكن الصين لما عملت انظمه معهم كما كانت
تسعى ايضا الى اقناع الطيران ين بالعوده
اليها بالتي هي احسن
بدل من استخدام القوه العسكريه التي لم
تتردد الصين في استخدامها في الوقت
المناسب لاستعاده طيوان مره اخرى هو كده
الوضع على بعض علاقتها ب الاحداث الاخيره
الاحداث الاخيره باختصار بعد ما تفهم كل
الخلفيات انه كانت اعتبرها مستعمره
بريطانيه لم يكن لديها اي قوانين تجبرها
على تسليم اي مجرمين الى الصين
لكن مؤخرا الصين ضغطت على السلطه الموجوده
فيها باعتبارها في الاخر يعني هي سلطه
تابعه لها على اه سنه قانون تسلم بموجبه
اي مجرم الى الصين المجرمين الجنائيين
القصه دي المفروض نظريا لا لا لا تغضب
احدا باعتبار اللي فيه اتفاقات مختلفه بين
دول اخرى لكن المساله اثارت الضعف لدى
عشرات الالاف من المواطنين في هذه ال
مقاطعه لانهم كانوا خايفين انه هو طبعا لا
يثقوا في القانون الصيني ولا يتقون فيه اه
الديمقراطيه الصينيه وبالتالي عندهم هاجس
انها دوله امنيه قمعيه لا لا يحب التعامل
معها انهى المفروض ان هي بلدهم في النهايه
هم كانوا خايفين ان المساله تبدا
بالاتفاقيه لتسليم المجرمين وبعدين تنتهي
او يتم تفسيرها بحيث يتم تسليم كل
المعارضين السياسيين وكل المنتقدين للصين
وبالتالي تختفي او تذوب تجربه
وتصبح ونقوم مثلها مثل هذه المدينه داخل
الصين وهو ما لا يحبه
فبدات اه احتجاجات عنيفه جدا هذه
الاحتجاجات الجبار
والصين على تجميد هذا القانون مؤقتا لكن
لو كان لاحظ بنلاحظ عده والحظ الاولنيه ان
الصين بتتبع سياسه النفس الطويل هي في
النهايه رفع شعار بلد واحده ونظامان لكن
يعني بتركز تدريجيا على الجزء الاول ان
فقط اللي هو بلد واحده اما حكايه النظام
ادى فهي
قليلا يعني يعني اسلوب تشوف يعني شويه
شويه هي بتغير
بحيث انها ترافق مع قوانينها لانها لن
تقبل
بؤره غربيه داخل الحدود
انه الغرب رغم انه في مظاهرات
حاشده فيهم وهي ليست الاولى حصلت مثلا سنه
2014 بردو اعتراضا على الحريات و تنديدا
بالقمع الصيني
المظاهرات تشبه الربيع العربي في
2011 و 2012
وحشود والمظاهرات تشبه الانتفاضات
والمظاهرات التي ظهرت في اوروبا الشرعيه
في التسعينات لكنها لاحظ انه موقف الغرب
مختلف هي ما حظيت باهتمام كبير من العرب
ما باهتمام اعلامي كبير الغرب ما حاول
سياسته لها لقلب النظام مثلا اللي موجود
في
والطريقه على الصين ده مرتبط بالسياسه
الغرب تكفين زينب يعتبر الغرب يعتبر الصين
خاص لكن في نفس الوقت عندهم مصالح كبيره
جدا مع وعشان عنده مصالح ضخمه جدا هو ب
يوازن انا ا ناصر الديمقراطيه لنا عم
حاولت ان اصرها في اوروبا الشرقيه
وان اصر ها في الدول العربيه عشان حقيقه
مصلحه والالوان اصرت ان تتضرر مسلحين ضرر
مصالحه
منازعات كبير جدا عند الصينيين وهما حاله
ال انكشاف
الاندماج مع الاقتصاد الصيني ضخم جدا فليس
هذا الوقت الذي يمكن ان يعبر فيه الغرب عن
تاييده هذه المظاهرات هل هذا الوضع يمكن
ان يستمر هذه القصه طويله تخضع بتطور
العلاقه بين الصين والغرب هو موقف الصين
من ديوان وموقف الصين من يعني الكثير من
القضايا المعلقه مع الغرب اشكركم والى
لقاء ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]